hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ihr kennt ja alle McDonald's und
Burger King Glitzer bereits im Titel wir
vergleichen heute nämlich die gleichen
Produkte die es bei McDonald's und
Burger King gibt dafür haben wir uns bei
McDonald's im Wert von 50 € Sachen
bestellt und genau die gleichen Produkte
auch bei Burger King im Wert von 50 €
die wird auf jeden Fall nichts
verschwendet gleich kommt noch eine
Menge Freunde von mir wir waren gestern
feiern und die freuen sich extrem ich
würde sagen wir starten ganz simpel hat
das übrigens serio
wir starten ganz entspannt mit dem
Hamburger
also bei dir sind auf jeden Fall so
Sesamkörner drauf
ganz normal Hamburger halten
[Musik]
mit dem Cheeseburger
Verpackung auch sehr sehr ähnlich
apropos packaging allerdings man lieben
Freunde bleibt auf jeden Fall dran bis
wir die Pommes testen weil burger King
hat Game changer entwickelt ich glaube
Burger McDonald's
[Musik]
ich weiß was du sagen musst ich wieder
Burger King ich sage aber hier auch
Meckes ja ist auch so ich finde dass der
Burger King Cheeseburger besser schmeckt
aber ich verbinde mit diesem
Cheeseburger meine alten Suchzeiten in
Bielefeld wo man mit 17 nach der
bauernparty bei McDonald's nur Cola
hatte so cheeseburg rausgehauen von
wegen Mac Menü blablabla sondern hast du
dir drei Cheeseburger direkt schicken
Burger drei Hamburg allerdings auch
schon zum dritten von diesen drei
günstigsten Burger bei McDonald's
boah erinnert mich auch so an früher
Burger King weil hier ist noch Salat
drauf und der schmeckt frischer hier ist
kein Salat drauf
also
als nächstes vergleichen wir den
bodenlosen fileto Fisch das sieht
einfach aus wie so eine Haut nach so
einer Akne Produkte Werbung
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
oh mein Gott gut
wieso essen wir nie diese Fischburger
für mich ist ein Unentschieden aber wenn
ich da rein weiß dieses Brot klebt oben
am Gaumen fest
weil die nicht
bewerten jede Kleinigkeit ich würde auch
Unentschieden sagen aber nur das Brot
habe ich krank gestört ne also richtig
gut dann würde sogar private Essen
ich nehme jetzt mal ein anderes Produkt
als Burger und zwar die Nuggets
ich habe ganz lange Zeit früher als ich
ein Kind war immer mal wenn wir weg zu
McDonald's fahren durften nach dem
Urlaub oder so mit der Family habe ich
nur Nuggets gegessen Burger damals war
Nuggets richtige Highlight Nuggets war
krank die haben sich auch nie verändert
nee es gibt auch immer diesen hier wenn
ihr Nuggets bestellt die sehen alle
gleich auseinander immer so ein runden
weil er immer ein mit so einem komischen
Ding oben
[Musik]
dran
sondern hat immer so dieses Ding was
aussieht wie irgendwie die Niere oder so
alle gleich aus mit diesem
Soße testen wir natürlich auch da haben
wir bei beiden hier für die Nuggets die
süß-sauer Soße genommen schreibt mir
auch in die Kommentare mit was essen
bitte jetzt aufhören Video zu gucken
pausieren in die Kommentare schreiben
weil voll viele Kollegen vom ersten
Currysoße für mich nur so ganz die Leute
die so Nuggets mit Ketchup oder Mayo
essen
ein bisschen Bruder
[Musik]
das ist das schwierigste Video dass ich
hier aufgenommen habe McDonald's ja
McDonald's
sind vergleichen wir jetzt die plant
Base also die veganen Nuggets von Burger
king mit den veganen Nuggets von
McDonald's dafür nehmen wir allerdings
nicht die süß-sauer Soße wie gerade
sondern die Currysoße
[Musik]
ah
weißt du was krass ist also die
McDonald's Nuggets haben schon eine ganz
andere Konsistenz und die haben auch
eine ganz andere Panade also sind viel
härter so von der Panade her die hier
sehen relativ identisch aus aber mit so
grünen Stückchen irgendwie drauf die
fand ich persönlich
so krass dass sie sogar noch mehr nach
Fleisch schmecken als normal
heftig unterwegs die haben das sieht man
auch wenn man da bestellt also wenn man
bestellt wir sind jetzt nicht
hingefahren oder so aber beim bestellen
konnte man wirklich bei McDonald's so
drei vier Produkte plant Base auswählen
so 20 oder so jetzt kommen wir jetzt zu
den Pommes meine Damen und Herren und da
habe ich ja zu Beginn schon gesagt
bleibt dran gebt euch das ich habe
nämlich noch nie gesehen bei McDonald's
Standardverpackung hier Pommes bei
Burger King allerdings die haben so eine
Box die sich verschließen lässt oben mit
allerdings Luftlöchern an den Seiten und
hier unten so dass die Pommes frisch
bleiben und du kannst dann einfach so
aufmachen hinlegen und dann halt Essen
bei McDonald's
was ich nie verstanden habe ist warum
die diese Pommes nicht mit Pommes Gewürz
Salzen willst du Paprika Gewürze ein
bisschen
ja das verstehe ich auch nicht das ist
zu teuer wahrscheinlich aber ich bin
sehr enttäuscht was
selbst niemals gedacht oh mein Gott
niemals gedacht diese Verpackung steht
doch nicht so gut wie wir denken
McDonald's 100 % oh mein Gott die sind
viel besser was man aber auch sagen muss
Burger King kam eine Viertelstunde eher
stimmt weil eigentlich sind die Burger
King Pommes deutlich besser ich glaube
das sagt jeder auf der ganzen Welt als
dritt letztes Produkt für heute
vergleichen wir die
Chili Cheese Nuggets von McDonald's und
Burger King
warum soll ich die Marke nochmal logisch
[Musik]
Unentschieden beides extreme Scheiße
große Scheiße wenn ich mich entscheiden
müsste Burger King bevor wir hier zum
letzten Produkt und damit einem
richtigen Banger kommen der Burger
nämlich bei jedem Restaurant mehr als
7,50 € gekostet das ist für die
Verhältnisse von fast and Ketten schon
echt sehr sehr teuer kommen der erst zum
Long Chicken der ist nämlich wirklich
exakt identisch packaging ist gleich
Name ist gleich man sieht auf jeden Fall
direkt dass der Salate bei McDonald's
sehr sehr tot wieder aussieht und was
man auch direkt sagen kann ist der
Burger King ähm Long Chicken ist auf
jeden Fall länger größer und höher also
man kriegt bei Burger King gefühlt mehr
es sieht auch frische aus
[Musik]
McDonald's hätte ich aber vorher nicht
gedacht weil vom Aussehen her der ist
größer dicker sieht frischer aus der
dagegen ist ein bisschen tot aber ich
habe mich trotzdem für den entschieden
letztes Produkt für heute meine Damen
und Herren wir haben uns bei McDonald's
den homemade Mac chrispy schicken
bestellt und bei Burger King den
Promotion small keine Ahnung wir
packening bei verwirrt
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
Papi PAP Cruise sind
[Musik]
eindeutig McDonald's
mit Ansage ist der beste Burger den ich
je gegessen habe bei McDonald's oder
Burger King der ist wirklich total guckt
euch allein diese Salat an hier an der
Seite das einzige was man noch ändern
könnte wäre der Käse das verstehe ich
nicht bei McDonald's
[Musik]
nicht verpassen wollt ich bin jetzt
gerade live auf Twitch also guck mal
unten in die Videobeschreibung ich
spiele Minecraft mit 100 Leute auf einem
Server also Text gerne mal ab ich heiße
Luca
echt